[Music]
on this sunday night
hours into the new coveted rules and the
rule breakers
are out hundreds show up for an
impromptu car show
in ontario the participants should be
ashamed of themselves what fines do they
now face
the surge in cases at work sites if
there's breakdowns in the system
we're going to see a pretty pretty
impressive rise in cases have protocols
lapsed plus the controversy over a
highway through one of the world's most
important
heritage sites and the constant reminder
of a canadian hero
40 years after the marathon of hope
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with breaking news
associated press is reporting that
american federal
agents have detained a woman trying to
cross from canada
into the united states the suspect in
question was wanted in connection with a
dangerous package that was intended for
the white house
the package contained the poison ricin
and it was addressed to u.s president
donald trump but was intercepted at a
sorting facility
the rcmp says it has been working with
the fbi because the package originated
from canada now to the other big story
concerns canada is in the second wave of
the pandemic
in quebec restrictions are ramping up to
fight off
a surge of covet 19. in the last 24
hours
new cases in quebec topped numbers that
haven't been seen since late may
that province recorded 462 new cases of
coven 19.
there was one death the hardest hit
areas are in the province's most
populated centers montreal and quebec
city
health officials raised the alert level
there late today imposing
even tougher restrictions to keep people
safe
they include limiting private gatherings
from 250 people
down to just 25. political leaders have
tried to limit gatherings in ontario
too but that doesn't seem to be working
just hours after new restrictions and
fines were announced in that
province police had to break up an
impromptu party
that drew in hundreds michael couture
reports
somehow this is still happening
warnings of a second wave new limits on
outdoor gatherings and threats of stiff
fines didn't stop hundreds of car lovers
from congregating in hamilton
saturday night is it worth a 750 fine
potentially
no no no
no yet there he was perhaps he was
laughing because hamilton police did
show up
but didn't hand out any tickets the
actions last night in light of the
concern with covet 19
are abhorrent the participants should be
ashamed of themselves
and if we can identify them and we are
able to lay charges down the road we
will certainly be doing that
ontario premier doug ford didn't pull
any punches saying in a statement quote
the reckless behavior that we saw in
ancaster last night
was totally unacceptable and it came
just
hours after ontario announced stricter
limits on outdoor
and indoor gatherings
cities across quebec have increased
police patrols to now include
bars and restaurants ensuring health
guidelines
are being followed brampton ontario has
been just as aggressive
and it's paid off we had bylaw out in
full force this weekend
but there was only three tickets that to
be issued and i put that in context our
worst weekend in july we had to issue
120 tickets
and if there isn't more of that we could
see more of this
thousands of cars snaked around the home
of the ottawa senators to get tested for
covet 19
at this pop-up facility dozens of
paramedics from across the region came
together over the weekend
to take some of the pressure off of
other testing centers
that have been overrun brewer park would
have been
insane trying to stand in line with him
for hours on end
with a sick child jackie laurette chose
to sit in her car for four hours instead
with schools being very strict she's
weighing another difficult decision
any symptom they show at school it's
either you get tested or they send us
home
kind of thinking of switching them to
homeschooling some say health officials
should have anticipated
increased demand for testing as students
went back to school
those on the front lines contend they're
trying to be as nimble as possible
the speed at which the hospitals our
paramedic partners in the community have
adjusted
we're doing the best that we can with
the amount of resources that we have to
work with
but more may be needed as the province
and the country brace
for the second wave of covet 19. mike
lacrouter global news ottawa
cases aren't just on the rise in ontario
and quebec spikes are being seen across
the country
here's the picture from the regions that
are reporting today
manitoba added 29 new cases most are in
winnipeg
saskatchewan saw 20 new cases and
nunavut has now recorded its first two
coronavirus cases
those two cases in northern canada are
raising concerns about
people who fly in and out of remote
communities for work
the two people who were infected worked
at a gold mine but acquired the virus
at home as heather york's west explains
health experts say it's more important
than ever for vulnerable communities
to remain vigilant knowing an outbreak
could be
devastating careful controls have spared
most of canada's northern communities
from the impact of covet 19. some of
that's just because of travel patterns
but another
major reason is because many of these
communities have taken
very very careful steps to prevent the
importation of covet 19.
a government spokesperson says two cases
recently reported at a nunavut gold mine
pose no risk to the surrounding
community but they do serve as a
reminder that as cases across the
country rise
work sites filled with a fly-in fly-out
workforce
are the perfect breeding ground for the
virus right now there are
four active outbreaks at work camps
within alberta's oil sands
as long as that kind of heightened
awareness is there
and prompt actions taken you know in
response to
positive tests or people with symptoms i
don't think that it poses a specific
risk
to the neighboring communities bc quebec
and alberta currently have the
highest case counts per capita but more
than six months into the pandemic
fatigue is setting in this calgary
restaurant owner says more and more
he's seeing customers unwilling to
follow covet 19 protocols
everyone is now starting to see more and
more issues every day with people not
wearing to mask refusing to wear masks
when they're ass wearing masks it's
everything from them walking out to
up into grabbing items throwing them
getting very aggressive up to the point
where near violence is occurring
and that's a big concern as summer
clicks to fall
and cold and flu season sets in we all
fill our end of the bargain we can
really ensure that that curve
doesn't skyrocket but of course if
there's breakdowns in the system
we're going to see a pretty pretty
impressive rise in cases a clear
reminder of what's at stake
for the months ahead heather urex west
global news
calgary the u.s is approaching a grim
milestone in the covet 19 pandemic
nearly 200
000 americans are confirmed to have died
from the virus though the real number is
likely higher
no other nation has recorded as many
deaths or cases
and as jackson proskow reports there are
predictions the number of fatalities
could more than
double by the end of 2020
six months and 200 000 deaths later
there are still new covid19 hot spots
popping up across the u.s
on average there are more than 35 000
new cases recorded nationwide
every single day there's still no plan
or strategy
will be 300 000 deaths by
december 1st and maybe even at 400 000
deaths by the time
of the next presidential inauguration
one influential model predicts 415 000
deaths by january 1st
decisions were made on some level to
open up and
i don't think that we had a good enough
hand on it nurse dana james saw the
worst of the pandemic at her florida
hospital in august
cases have come down she worries
americans will let down their guard
allowing the virus to surge again walk
one day in my shoes
have one 12 hour shift alongside with me
and maybe you'll change your mind
despite all that's been lost the u.s is
still wrapped up in the same debate
about how to respond
president donald trump continues to
question the effectiveness of masks
there are a lot of people think the
masks are not good he's defying covet 19
restrictions with indoor rallies
while promising magical cures the virus
will disappear it will disappear
every day americans are waging the same
fight themselves
despite the virus spreading largely
uncontrolled there's still a push to
reopen everything from schools to
restaurants and bars
we can do all those things but you've
got to do one thing we've got to bring
the entire nation down
to some agreed upon low level of
containment
that may mean turning back the clock
bringing back some restrictions
especially over the winter
we should be ready to impose mandates
in order not to overwhelm our hospitals
and save lives so let's not repeat the
same mistake we meant before
there's plenty of hope riding on the
development and deployment of a vaccine
but that could take a year or more to
happen
and in the meantime kovit 19 continues
to spread far
and wide and there's little being done
to stop it
robin jackson frosco in washington
thanks jackson the u.s
president plans to submit his nominee
for the supreme court this week and he
says
it will be a woman democrats are pushing
back just as the republicans did when
they blocked barack obama's nominee as
jennifer johnson reports this is just
another fight that centers
around the november election
[Applause]
with crowds cheering fill that seat at a
campaign rally
u.s president donald trump promised he
will do just that within days of justice
ruth bader ginsburg's passing
i will be putting forth the nominee next
week
it will be a woman senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell is promising an
immediate hearing critics are calling
him a hypocrite
after mcconnell blocked president barack
obama's supreme court pick
for over nine months saying it was too
close to an election
democrats at a supreme court vigil for
ginsburg are sounding the alarm
mitch mcconnell and his henchmen
believe that they can ram through
a supreme court justice
only 45 days from the election
this fight has just begun
senate democrats need just four
republicans to block the nomination
already two senators susan collins and
lisa murkowski
have said the decision should be made
after the november third election
house speaker nancy pelosi is vowing to
stop the president
even if it means launching a new
impeachment hearing against him
we have our options we have arrows in
our quiver
that i'm not about to discuss right now
the president hasn't released a list of
names of potential female nominees
but many believe amy coney barrett is a
front-runner for the seat
believed to be anti-abortion and
anti-gay marriage judge barbara lagoa a
hispanic woman from swing state florida
is also considered a top contender both
are trump appointees to federal
appellate benches
if the shoe were on the other foot and
the democrats had the white house
and the senate they would right now be
trying to confirm another member of the
supreme
court even before a name has been
submitted tempers are flaring
further igniting what has already been a
bitter contentious
election year jennifer johnson global
news
washington a u.s federal judge has
blocked donald trump's attempt to ban
the popular messaging app
wechat the judge ruled a ban would raise
questions about first amendment rights
which guarantee
free speech wechat has more than a
billion active users worldwide
it's owned by chinese tech giant 10 cent
the american government wanted to ban
wechat and tick tock
another chinese-owned app citing
national security concerns
but president trump is changing his tune
on tick-tock
he's approved a deal for oracle and
walmart to acquire stakes
in tick tock's u.s operations
the security will be 100 they'll be
using separate clouds and a lot of
very very powerful security it will have
nothing to do with china
it'll be totally secure that'll be part
of the deal
the proposed deal calls for the three
businesses to form a new
u.s company coming up the push to rename
a canadian mountain
will explain the offensive history
behind it
and some firsts in this year's tour de
france meet the young man making history
for his country
the canadian government is planning to
remove an offensive name from a mountain
in banff national park
indigenous groups in alberta say this is
a step in the right direction
and they're now working on coming up
with a new name as jamie dahl explains
momentum
is building to rename other prominent
parts of the canadian rockies
and a warning some language in this
story is offensive
it's hiked on camp dawn bike dawn
tunnel mountain is one of the most
frequented peaks in alberta's bow valley
and for generations of first nations
people it's a sacred place
they held ceremonies there they held
trading they traded there at the
mountain
and so on visited there and so on
it was a gathering place the name tunnel
was given to this mountain following a
mistake by a surveyor for the railway
who thought a tunnel might have to be
drilled through it it didn't happen but
the name stuck
however the indigenous people already
had a name for it
it was called ini
in english buffalo mountain it's easy to
see why they called it what they did
a petition is now in the works to put
pressure on the provincial government to
change the name to sacred buffalo
guardian mountain
it's one of those wonderful things we
can do that i would call
forward reconciliation in other words it
will enrich us
all and it will name this feature in a
much more descriptive and powerful way
and there's agreement across all the
first nations with association with this
place
in nearby canmore an effort is also
being made to change the name of a
distinct rocky landmark
this peak doesn't actually have an
official name but the one
commonly used does pop up on maps and
blogs
and many are wondering why to use a name
like squaws tit
it's just another way that the
mainstream society is saying to
indigenous people like
we don't care about you and it's not
just like about
squeamishness or morality it's about
ethics and social
justice and caring for our fellow and
sister human beings on this planet
it shows a lack of care for human life
and respect
there have already been two attempts to
give the peak a lasting less
offensive name but they haven't been
approved i will say the government of
alberta has been very supportive
and part of it is coming up with a name
that
really is in keeping with the rich
history and tradition of this area
and we need to be really intentional
about that and make sure that the name
that
is chosen is one that will stick and
that
is one that will do justice to this
beautiful mountain
the buffalo treaty speaks to culture
conservation there's little arguing
about what name tunnel mountain should
be changed to among first nations groups
in 2018 bison were reintroduced to the
landscape of banff national park
and indigenous leaders agree it's also
time to bring back the original name of
the mountain
resting in the heart of this iconic
place
jb dog global news banff alberta
still ahead heritage versus highway the
concerns over a new road near
egypt's pyramids
you're watching global national
[Music]
take a look at this footage out of
france tonight a drone captured the
moment a mobile home was swept away by
flood waters
the southern part of the country has
been inundated with heavy rainfall
leading to flash flooding at least two
people have been reported missing
a highway project outside cairo has
conservationists concerned
the new road runs through an area dotted
with ancient
pyramids the government insists no
historic sites are being affected
but as mike armstrong explains critics
say the project may be paving its way
through
undiscovered archaeological sites
the egyptian government already tried to
build this highway once
the project was started in the 1990s but
suspended after an international outcry
well it's going ahead now barely two
kilometers from a unesco world heritage
site
too close says a former senior unesco
official
who already fought against it once
normally
in a world heritage site or in the
buffer zone because the world heritage
site has a buffer zone around it
which allows some construction provided
has been an
environmental impact study made before
one section of the new highway cuts
right through a pyramid plateau
south of cairo among those on one side
are the red pyramid and the bent pyramid
on the other several more including pepe
the first
and second as well as the step pyramid
now the step is the oldest of all
pyramids it was built about 4 600
years ago at that point in history the
region was in fact the egyptian
capital city of memphis it had lavish
palaces
it was a thriving city and it was the
largest city in egypt during that time
critics say the highway would mean more
pollution from vehicles that could
damage pyramids it might even mean
paving over archaeological sites that
haven't been discovered
the government insists that isn't
happening
the minister of tourism and antiquities
says nothing is being
touched that any project in egypt has to
be approved by the antiquities ministry
first the government says the highway is
needed for development
and points out there are existing roads
even closer to the pyramids now
but there are critics and there could be
more some archaeologists contacted by
global news
admit there's resistance to speak out
publicly
because there's fear if they do the
government might not give them permits
to work in the country mike armstrong
global news
up next there's no stopping them now how
canadians continue to honor terry fox's
legacy
40 years later
[Applause]
has a lot to celebrate tonight the 22
year old rode in his first tour de
france and won
this year's yellow jersey he's the first
slovenian to ever win the three-week
event
he's also the youngest man to secure the
tour de france's top spot
since the second world war the popular
race is normally held in july but its
start date was pushed back
by the pandemic this month we are
honoring a canadian hero who made a mark
on our lives 40 years ago
when he took it upon himself to run
across canada to raise money for cancer
research
he never finished his dream but others
are doing it for him
way to go matthew take matthew white
from nova scotia
he completed his 40th marathon 40 years
after fox's marathon of hope
white's runs raised over five thousand
dollars he completed his goal on the
same day
thousands of other canadians ran walked
or cycled
in the annual terry fox run fox couldn't
complete his goal because bone cancer
had spread to his lungs
cyclists in bc rode for six hours to
raise money for cancer research
among them was a 15 year old who
survived the same form of cancer as
terry fox
jacob brendenhoff also had his leg
amputated
that didn't slow him down as he rode
alongside fox's brother daryl
brendan hoff's ride raised nearly 90
thousand dollars
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm robin gill
we leave you tonight with the peace
tower in ottawa flying the flag
half-mast
in memory of former canadian prime
minister john turner
turner died friday he was canada's 17th
prime minister thank you for watching
good night
[Music]